jetzt versauen die klimakaoten auch noch
den Ferienstart in Hamburg und
Düsseldorf legen die Umweltaktivisten
die flughäfenlahm kleben sich so wie
hier auf den rollfeldern fest in Hamburg
ist am Donnerstag der erste Tag der
Sommerferien durch tausende Urlauber
stecken fest dies teilt der
Flughafenbetreiber auf seiner Homepage
mit in den frühen Morgenstunden hatten
sich die klimakaoten Zugang zum
Flughafen verschafft blockieren seither
Start und Landebahn laut ersten
Meldungen durchtrennten die Chaoten
einen Zaun am Flughafen Gelände und
fuhren anschließend mit Fahrrädern auf
das Vorfeld des Flugplatzes und auf die
Rollbahnen wo sie sich festgeklebt haben
das gleiche Bild auch in Düsseldorf am
Flughafen auch hier stoppen die
klimakämpfer den Flugverkehr indem sie
sich aufs Rollfeld leben die Polizei ist
vor Ort wie und wann es für die Urlauber
weitergeht unklar die Stimmung Tausender
Urlauber dürften sie mit den Aktionen
gründlich versaut haben